focus japan mit globetrotter am
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte die
reise bald wied globetrotters punkt ch
[Musik]
ich bin patrick rohr letzte woche bin
ich als fotograf und journalist
sozialplan
ich hoffe wirkstoff zu hoffen das buch
[Musik]
gestartet habe ich meine reis vorwort
tokio
die letzte tag bin ich marine bergdorf
die chora im westen von laxey jetzt bin
ich unterwegs von achim nur durch statt
es gibt grund warum ich genau in die
stadt will 2011 hat der tsunami oder
komplett zerstört
onagawa islamische staat plexi tat die
sich mancher handy grund
der tsunami hat alles klingt gleich mehr
oder manches aber gibt hat man alles
genau
827 lied sind hier zur lage war ins
labor
statt herzlich vom tsunami noch immer
nicht erholt
oft sind weggezogen und mit zurückkommen
hinterlassen so nah war ein drittel
weniger liegt ausfuhren zunahmen ist als
beleg zu richten jetzt geht zum zentrum
kairos meine reise begleitet eines gens
und wir sind immer konnten sich
übernachten
am nächsten morgen ist der begriff
koscher fortschritten ist der erste
drucker nicht gestern onagawa entsteht
nicht nur mehr sondern vor allem rund
ums alte zentrum der hang zum teil hat
man den letzten jahr ganz neu
aufgeschüttet damit von lösungen zur
kunstform fast so sicher sind
als neue zentrum militärs vor der
katastrophe auch meter hat mehr hilfe
schüttet wohnhäuser g20 hatten und recht
rat der bürgermeister seine zentrum soll
ein begegnungsort werden üblicherweise
fängt man in der japanischen
gesellschaft erst mit 60 an
verantwortungen für viele sachen zu
übernehmen
ich glaube dass meine generation die
verantwortung für die ersten schritte
der wiederauferstehung dieser stadt
übernehmen soll
in japan gibt es viele regeln die
einschränken wenn wir nach der
zerstörung hier einen neuen ort frei
gestalten könnten sehe ich das als große
chance
was kannst du darüber sagen einheimische
die geblieben sind haben neue
geschäftsideen und junge leute kommen
nun von außen her und starten hier in
onagawa ein neues business wie zum
beispiel der junge herr mit seinen
gitarren shop dort drüben oder bringt
das tokyo und geschäftsführer von acker
gezogen
[Musik]
das ja mach mit seinem team ganz
spezielle gitarre elektrogitarre frog
aber traditionelle musik und detail
waren verliebt nicht verdoppelt
was war für sie der grund hierher nach
onagawa zu kommen
dieses geschäft aufzumachen und hier
gitarren zu produzieren
als ich das erste mal hierherkamen
spürte ich dass diese orte eine starke
energie ausstrahlt die leute versuchten
bereits neue geschäftsideen umzusetzen
die firmen zum beispiel möchten neu nach
übersee verkaufen
so dachte ich diese stadt ist ein
wunderbarer ort um ein gutes produkt
herzustellen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dieser rief ist ein gitarren intro der
schweizer band gotthard
[Musik]
der bürgermeister ist ein rocker rechten
heavy metal band
[Musik]
mit
dollar
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin also sehr viel druck der
richtigen richtung gotthard komme ich
nicht heran und war als konzert
sachs ja noch eine zunahme wohnen im
grund den sieg holt an und forscht ohne
privatsphäre
und die neue siedlungen im oberen teil
von der stadt sind zwar schön und modern
aber hautnah anonym
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen im hohlweg trafik im
hof ashika hammer hammer vorort vor
nokia daran fest
und von dort vor der familie verteilen
dritter generation die jetzt nach
missionar mit komplett zerstört sie
insgesamt hat der 44
führung
da hilft betreibern mehr wasser
[Musik]
jetzt wo hier alles so friedlich ist
kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen was
das meer versank plötzlich von der
unglaublich zerstörerische kraft
[Musik]
ich sage auch das stört wurde da wusste
ich das ist es neues
sind dort die zunahme mit mit dem vater
im haus ziehen mitunter sind sie seien
geflüchtet
aber es regnet es war die maschine
schneller reagiert und war schockiert
[Musik]
dort hat man neue hügel mit immer mehr
betrifft gewohnt erhöhter manche sind
trotzdem marke zocker aber im qualys sei
der blickkontakt haushalte durch und
nach bahrain kontakt untereinander als
fehler
historische oder auch die dann ohne
jetzt haben einfach ein meter brett und
mehrere eigentlich für das la paz
gelabert von mir mit dem fisch und nicht
das gleiche mehr tod und verderben über
iris dorf braucht hat in der fabrik noch
etwas hat sie verraten werden es gibt
mir ein gutes leben und ertrag wenn ich
mich anstrenge über trotz der angst
schätze ich das meer immer noch sehr
auto ist direkt hinter dem damm sie als
höchst vor der familie gestanden
courbis kanada die regeln gelten
doch sex ist lang sie da obwohl es im
moment sehr mühsam ist bleibe ich vor
allem an ihren zwei töchtern zurück ich
bin seit 30 jahren fischer und kann mir
schlecht vorstellen woanders zu leben
mit einem anderen beruf natur wo geht
übernimmt der mehrzahl eher mit die
rechtslage
[Musik]
vor der wenige gebäude zu lager war wo
nach dem tsunami entstanden sind ist
später erstellt 16 meter über meer und
das vor zwanzig jahren bot hat herr marx
hat glück dass es hoch genug ist damit
für tsunami geschützt war
[Musik]
ganz gelenkt hatte allerdings doch nicht
das wasser ist auch zum transport der
hat so geflirtet
die ganze dauerte vom spital patienten
dossiers alles ist damals zerstört wurde
so hoch ist was du damals co
später hat man noch mit zunahme mit
spannender gehalt aus der schweizer
aufgebot
neu auf der oberste beide steckt alters
und pflegeheim untergebracht
ich darf hier fotografieren ich will mir
das allerdings mit marisa zielflagge
hauptverdiener bitte ziehen sie für
ihren einsatz die angestellten uniform
an die wir hier täglich tragen
wir würden uns freuen wenn sie uns heute
mithelfen könnten gar nicht vorstellen
ich werde da man schaut ja es wurden
menschen aus dem erdgeschoss weggespült
unsere angestellten im ersten stock
kamen knapp mit dem leben davon
das wasser drang ein schwan und
schwemmte sie an die decke hoch
sie hat nur noch knapp 30 zentimeter
luft über sich dann ließ das wasser
glücklicherweise nach sofort nach dem
tsunami war schwierig zu begreifen dass
das was sich vor unseren augen abspielte
die realität war und nicht etwa ein
alptraum
ich glaube dass sie in der oberen
abteilung bereits einige vom personal
kennengelernt haben alle angestellten
die an jenem tag im spital gearbeitet
hatten wussten zuerst nicht was mit
ihren häusern und ihren familien
geschehen war
trotz dieser bedrückenden ungewissheit
sind sie pflichtbewusst im spital
geblieben und haben sich unermüdlich und
die patienten gekümmert
wer noch mit zunahmen hövel it werkzeuge
sind hat sie niemals großer spital
gebracht dafür dass platz seines autos
platt heimat hallo alle miteinander wie
schon am morgen angekündigt haben wir
heute gesucht guten tag guten tag
dann schlage ich vor dass wir nun
unseren übungen machen
auch die füße bewegen
man hat mehr platz gebraucht erzählt
dass sanader war geht es wie in ganz
japan namen trägt die einzieht ist das
schön
anders sieht das problem will klickt
sieht die geburtenrate rapide sinkt
darum sind der trend alles andere als
gesichertes japan dass mancher hier
immer älter werden und hat verschiedene
gründe abend und appenzell und uns zu
und hat systemisches für den best of der
ganze wald bis von in deutschland älter
bis zu tod werden händler klappt das
japan immer der fall
und immer weniger junge geht gibt's
einmal weniger personal für die alte
menschen
[Musik]
erlöse würde sich das problem vermutlich
nur wenn sie mir zu waren aus dem
ausland kabel
doch da japan zerstörte sind hocherfreut
personal nicht einmal zwei prozent der
bevölkerung sind island
[Musik]
macht sich sorgen sollen sich in zukunft
um die auto kümmern
tendenziell leben die jungen nicht mehr
bei den eltern
alte menschen werden allein gelassen
oft wohnt eine alte person allein in
einem haus dazu er und ein anderer
gesellschaftlicher trend immer mehr
junge mancher beschließen und auf single
what was geht die mit weniger junge wo
heiratet der familie mit dem kind hat
[Musik]
ich glaube dass es mehr braucht als das
wenn die heute verteilt lebenden
familien wieder wie früher zueinander
finden und miteinander leben würden dann
würde wohl eine bessere gesellschaft
entstehen denke ich es ist wichtig dass
die verbindung wieder gestärkt wird
zwischen einzelnen leuten und den
familien auch lokal im dorf das ist der
richtige weg
[Musik]
dieser vorträge für japan sind groß 30
jahres aus dem land ein drittel weniger
manche gar und die meisten von ihnen
sind dann im pensionsalter
ich habe keine ahnung welchen kollaps
vor dem land laut verhindern
ich habe auf plakaten von alcoa für
klärt und 14
zumal seine arbeit ist 100 jahre alt
sie hatten immer viel zu
[Musik]
es sind intensive tags im norden
zwei wochen bin ich jetzt aber der
tennis mit der reise begleitet haben wir
derzeit viele türen aufgemacht und viele
begegnungen ermöglicht und hat ein
filter zählt über die japanische kultur
doch herz müsse zurück in die schweiz
zurück ins büro
nicht
am bahnhof tokio nahmen abschied von
einer handvoll jetzt haben wir hoffen
mit hilfe lokaler besetzerinnen
er forderte reise gar nicht mit
allerdings am bahnhof noch im job
gestellt ich dort helfer einen
schulkonsens putzer eine von einer
hochgeschwindigkeits zurück dass dort
jetzt sind wir locker ist es aber gar
nicht weiß was für woche aussprechen
japan hat einen crashkurs wichtigste
seite ist der mir richtig faltet sich
und wenn wir es nur richtig habe so
stecke cortex
und dann leer ich mir meine zukunft
passagiere richtig empfand richtig
gehört reinigungspersonal begriffs zuzog
und passagier mit
und dein geld floss drei menü passagier
zum stiege und dann rund commander
zunutze
wie ihr vorgänger und 63 stellen ford
richtig und rasch passiert dir vertraut
[Musik]
naja
minute helmes zieht von der ganze wagen
zum glück wie bis 28
das wird heiss geschafft aufrollen mini
kollegin hat es geschafft sechs monate
lang ist wie alle ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen in duisburg bevor sie zum
ersten mal allein zu verputzen die
versteuerung
es ist aber auch das fördern
der zug war pünktlich ab drei jahren hat
den shinkansen paragraf netten minuten
verspätung
[Musik]
mit 36 27 vom land aber natürlich
yoshida
[Musik]
mittlerweile hat er ihr getrennt doch
ohne wachstum wird ja nicht plastikhülle
regentonne
[Musik]
es gelte moment begriffe dem asphalt
melodie erzielt
[Musik]
das volkslied steht am straßenrand
der grund warum ist eigentlich gar nicht
wahre grund sind japanische spezialität
[Musik]
q cells um die 60 franken am bau sind
die private studie von den familien ich
war das erfolgsrezept von einer guten
übernehmen werden verraten
[Musik]
dann sagte mir das kabinett mit mir die
rede und der schafe im supermarkt
eric jan akkermann 18 jahre geschehen
abend pro woche schaffte dem lotter
albert verdienen
verschiedene große träume zu erfüllen
will es machen und das sind es also die
oder nudeln warum braucht es drei jahre
um zu lernen wie man sie herstellt was
macht das so schwierig neben den nudeln
geht es auch um die beilagen und den
richtigen geschmack der suppe
das alles zu lernen ist gar nicht so
einfach und kann sehr wohl drei jahre
dauern
[Musik]
erste risse
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist ja die bkk heiß kochen im
jugendclub die bei der jungen freiheit
eier und kritiker sind zum ersten mal
hier bin ich sie zeigen wie modern macht
als erster ins wasser von fuji
spezielles mal und fünf gramm salz mit
dem nachmittag
[Musik]
oder nur hand sondern fürs gemacht
kaká hat jeder gesehen hat kann ich dann
wirklich drauf stehen das ist die
erfahrung für mich
ich spüre muskeln nicht so verdienen
kann ich mir dachte mir okay
der einzig offizielle oder club ccc jahr
bitte gründig historiker nürnberg sie
aber schon damals handy oder nudeln
fasziniert und noch hinter twitter jedes
mal meine oder nudeln macht neue tricks
und theater und textur fluss sogar in
jeder kunst auf genauigkeit da geht es
oft um rico freimuth mache pariert mich
dazu wasser bereitet inzwischen zog
bevor annimmt sojasauce ziemlich viel
mehr als normalerweise in der suppe und
miso baustoffs region
lacht viel und wann denn zubereitet
zeigt mit zwei heft gibt dann rudern
heft ja bist du wer macht das du ich bin
wirklich beeindruckt
woher kommt deine leidenschaft vom
geschmack der geht mir direkt ins herz
noch nicht weißt du dass sie glänzen
wenn sie fertig sind
da es gibt wirklich viele kleine
geheimnisse beim rudern machen
[Musik]
bis zum schluss ist reger völlig
konzentriert mit kaltem wasser wartet
nun ab
[Musik]
meine ersten selbst gemachten vorschlag
kann jetzt nur monitor das sind
thunfisch locker und chili flop
produzieren
die sind ziemlich scharf nudel sind
herrlich und darf man blut lasse dürfe
dafür schaffen erklärt ich freue mich
bekannt dass gottes yoshida
[Musik]
die aktie war beschäftigen minute machen
für sie am besten abschalten
endlich einmal meine gedanken ums leben
bekommen immer mehr als bild früher
hätte auch die kreise statt
[Musik]
der bauernhof hero patienten bzw in rom
station und vor 20 jahren hat man als
japan sehr kontrovers diskutiert die
einheit gefunden als ich ein schandfleck
für die historische stadt die anderen
sind begeistert sie vom futuristischen
look
[Musik]
kyoto schon sehr lebendige moderne stadt
quito hatte als einzige große stationen
historische hahn
[Musik]
der grund das thema alte teil hat es das
team zweiter weltkrieg als einzige große
station vor den bombardements ist
verschont geblieben
[Musik]
das klappern die wichtigste wochen im
jahr
der vierte frühling der anfang vom leder
zieht klopp das hotel zu finden ist fast
unmöglich kann ich mir vorstelle
im roboter nein das hat es noch nie aber
hoppla hier ist der lift für männer und
frauen getrennt
rotes für frauen
denn der name einer stunde hat hotel
will mehr für 1 8 in der stadt nicht
mehr braucht als gewinn stunde heißt und
für toiletten zu schlafen
eine zum iftar alles ist reduziert
nichts wesentlich neues gebracht hat es
wenig platz natürlich ist das bistum
winkel war nicht jünger war ich würde
wahrscheinlich möglichst viele mutige
hatten aber nach der jetzt bin ich ganz
ehrlich sehr froh dass vorläufig markt 1
[Musik]
nach des kurz aber dafür habe ich
geschlafen
ich bin froh mit mir übersetzerin teuer
mache ich nicht erwartet story okamoto
eine der weniger kampfkunst trainerin
voss japan geht kuka motors 280 kitas
ein sei ein kino lehrerin und reiter
sagte dann dasteht schwarzen gurt dh und
das ist sehr schnell klar wer ist jetzt
gab es zu seinem sitz meditation
währenddessen sitzt du die augen sie
nicht geschlossen
[Musik]
eine erste lektion in kampfkunst ist das
moor kunstgenuss internet kämpfen
[Musik]
40 minuten im lotussitz im schnitt
bewegen
grades leon durchschnaufen gedanken und
widerlager ersparen die erfahrung
[Musik]
richtig schnüren und zentriert sie ist
immer wieder sehr wichtig dass wir nicht
schön aber man kann ich voll dabei
ich muss mir meine fotos wieder mal ab
ich finde das gehört wohl einer sitzbank
so in beziehung zu den menschen und
anders sieht wirklich so teilten ganze
geschehen will ich nun ihr eigen gemacht
und drohen mit reaktion war ziemlich
merkwürdig dass besonders harte schnitte
wenigstens geputzt ist die harmonie ist
die energie ist also der weg die energie
zu harmonisieren zu harmonisieren mit
der natur und jedem einzelnen individuum
und ding das auf der welt existiert ich
habe das ganze welt
alle sind los
niemand redet es wurden
du arbeitest ohne worte fordern sie dir
einfach wie können sich die natur und
all die schönen dinge erklären
sie sind einfach schlimm du musst sie
sehen und fühlen wahrnehmen
das ist im grunde dasselbe es gibt
nichts zu erklären für mich war für sie
und sie müssen es fühlen
[Musik]
der weg des aikido ist zu akzeptieren
ohne sich daran zu klammern
ohne widerstand er gibt es noch nicht
wenn du aggressiv bist und ich werde
auch dann knallt es
wenn du wütend ist brauche ich aber
nicht wütend auf dich zu sein
ich akzeptiere es und lenke es um ist in
zwei personen
ich kann dich und mich aber auch aus der
perspektive einer dritten person
beobachten wie wenn ich uns in einem
film sehen würde wenn du also wütend
fest brauche ich das nicht persönlich zu
nehmen
genau das geschieht auch interesses
meditation
eigentlich würde fotografie dass der
index das bild sagt mehr als tausend
worte würde aikido mein leben verändern
ich weiß nicht was möchtest du denn
verändern
konzentriert genau darum geht es beim
aikido langsam verstehe durchaus so viel
mehr als sport eskaliert mit
krafttraining auf situationen richtig zu
reagieren
klarheit respekt und genauso erlaubt
yoko faszinieren die frau
er gehört
motto hatten unglaublich laabidi und
vielfältige beizuziehen
[Musik]
keines dieser krieg übersetzt heißt das
sagte laden zum sitzen was mit hektisch
das manchmal ganz verschiedene linien
kriegt reus war
[Musik]
die letzten zwei wochen
sanader hatte bürgermeister block
[Musik]
die verstaubte die 100 jahre
fotografiert tsunami alles verloren hat
und radio kann klärt vor mir selber
druck hat
[Musik]
die nächsten und letzten folge war für
mich das dritte von rechts ein trampel
dann gar nicht auf okinawa eine inseln
im süden blieben die älteste mannschaft
der welt sehr herzlich empfangen und
zahlen aus dem süden auf der insel
ishigaki jähriger butzbacher thomas
[Musik]
focus japan mit globetrotter am
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
bald wied globetrotters punkt ch